اداره بايدن تريد الصلاحيه للتعامل مع
مخاطر التيك توك للتاكد من ان البيانات
الحساسه ليست مكشوفه للصين من اجل الحصول
على هذا النوع من الرقابه يدفع البيت
الابيض الكونجرس لمنحه سلطه قانونيه على
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي يتم تطوير هذا
التشريع من قبل السيناتور الديمقراطي مارك
وارنار واذا تمريره يمكن ان يكون للحكومه
الامريكيه سلطه حظر تيك توك المملوكه
للصينيين بشكل كامل من الولايات المتحده
لكن حسب نيويورك تايمز ليس هذا هو الهدف
فكره التشريع هي السماح لتيك توك بالعمل
في الولايات المتحده ولكن تحت اعين
الحكومه الساهره يبدو ان منصه تيك توك على
وشك ان تصبح احدث اضافه في حرب
التكنولوجيا بين واشنطن وبكين حرب تنطوي
على العديد من الفصول الاخرى ابرزها
بعنوان الرقائق الدقيقه
في السنوات الاخيره انفقت الولايات
المتحده 52 مليار دولار على تصنيع اشباه
الموصلات المحليه لتقليل اعتماد امريكا
على رقائق الكمبيوتر المصنوعه في اسيا
بينما منعت الصين منذ فتره طويله العديد
من الخدمات الامريكيه عبر الانترنت ابرزها
جوجل ومتى ويوتيوب